who are the faceless men it depends on
who is asking to a penitent they may be
relief to evict him they may be
vengeance to a lord they may be an
incredible expense and to the iron bank
they may be just another asset nobody
but the faceless men know their origin
that the order is rumored to predate the
founding of Braavos we know only that
they reside in or are somehow aligned
with the house of black and white had
old and lonely building a few who enter
ever leave some whisper that those where
wood doors open not on a house but on to
the world of the dead from whence the
faceless men rise when summoned we can
dismiss such foolishness as we do the
fishwives who spread it the house of
black and white is merely a temple
consecrated to the many-faced God and
filled with snatcher II of his many
faces the old gods of Westeros the Lord
of Light the Black Goat the Lion of
night the weeping lady a stranger
perhaps now you understand what is
worshipped here and along with them
other gods hunan alive now recognize
brought here long ago by sailors never
came again unlike the priests of other
religions the servants here preached no
sermons and perform no ceremonies as far
as one can see silence and solitude form
the whole of their worship as well as
collecting the occasional devotee if one
wants to engage a faceless man one
visits the house of black and white and
pays the price as for what that may be
those who have paid it rarely speak of
it for make no mistake from the moment
the faceless men accept your offer
the man you named is dead though he
doesn't note
perhaps not that day perhaps not that
year but soon and inevitably many would
say you are as much his murderer as if
you'd swung an axe yourself just as many
would say that's the point